ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um das Thema künstliche
Intelligenz in Art eines Rückblicks wir
wollen uns damit befassen mit den Fragen
wieefern kann KI intelligent oder gar
autonom genannt werden wie ist die
Menschmaschine Interaktion zu denken
damit die Würde des Menschen nicht
verletzt wird also Mensch interagiert
mit Maschine wie z.B künstlicher
Intelligenz und wir können und sollen KI
Systeme medizinische Diag en stellen
können Sie das und wenn sie es können
dürfen sie es das ist eine spannende
Frage die auch die Frage nach der
Verantwortung im Umgang mit Technik und
Mensch
betrifft die aktuelle Bedeutung von
künstliche Intelligenz ist liegt da auf
der Hand KI künstliche Intelligenz ml
ist die Abkürzung für Maschines lernen
maschinelles Lernen oder machine
learning wir sehen künstliche
Intelligenz wird zunehmend in ganz
verschiedenen Bereichen des Alltags
eingesetzt es beginnt GZ ganz banal mit
Computerspielen wenn wir
computerspielgegner haben die nicht
menschlich gestört werden Texterkennung
OCR optical character recognition
Spracherkennung immer mehr wenn Sie ein
Google home System haben oder Alexa von
Amazon wie sie alle heißen Kunst wir
werden gleich auf ein Beispiel eingehen
sie können mit textbefehlen auch Kunst
generieren und nicht zuletzt vielleicht
auch vor allem Medizin in der
medizinischen Diagnostik wird häufig
auch künstliche Intelligenz eingesetzt
beim Erkennen von Krankheit
Mustererkennung ja Alpha go haben wir
schon gesehen ist ein spannendes
Programm was auch go Spieler besiegen
kann ich mache oben rechts den Link rein
zu dieser Sitzung wo wir uns damit
befasst haben aber auch in der Kunst D
E2 ist ein Programm mit dem wir
realistische Bilder erzeugen können so
wie es hier steht jetzt habe ich hier
mal ein Beispiel von einem Roboter und
der wurde erzeugt mittels künstliche
Intelligenz als ich gesagt habe male mir
doch
ein Bild ein
impressionistisches Ölgemälde mit einem
Roboter der eine rote Blume in der Hand
hält und das wurde mir ausgespuckt und
es wurde noch eins ausgespuckt das sah
dann so aus jetzt kann man sich drüber
Stre was ist eher impressionistisch
wahrscheinlich eh das linke das rechte
ist eher expressionistisch jedenfalls
sieht man in der Kunst es wird schon
viel dadurch verändert nicht nur in der
Kunst stellen sich diese Frage sind auch
in der Ethik wir müssen folgende Fragen
behandeln aufwerfen diskutieren ist
künstliche Intelligenz ein Subjekt kann
künstliche Intelligenz Handeln besitzt
künstliche Intelligenz was wie
Intentionalität das bedeutet
gerichtetheit kognitive gerichtheit ist
künstlich Intelligenz autonom autonom
meint kann künstliche Intelligenz sich
selbstgesetze geben und auch danach
handeln oder bekommt künstlich
Intelligenz die Gesetze immer von außen
gegeben wir müssen uns von vier
problematischen Position abgrenzen
Ideologisierung also so zu tun als ob in
der künstlichen Intelligenz das Heil der
Menschheit liegt als ob künstliche
Intelligenz alle Probleme lösen könnte
anthropomorphisierung bedeutet dass wir
künstliche Intelligenz vermenschlichen
oder Banalisierung dass wir sie nur als
ein technisches Hilfsmittel wie z.B ein
Hammer verstehen das würde gerade
künstlich Intelligenz unterschätzen wir
müssen also irgendwi da so ein Mittelweg
finden wir dürfen Sie natürlich auch
nicht dramatisieren wie können wir das
tun das ist eine ganz wichtige Aufgabe
für die technikethik erstmal müssen wir
verschiedene Formen künstlich
Intelligenz unterscheiden und überhaupt
einen Einblick bekommen in das
gesamtphänomen künstliche Intelligenz
unterscheiden zwischen symbolverarbeiten
der künst künstliche Intelligenz das ist
die traditionelle künstliche Intelligenz
die wir bislang kannten sie manipuliert
Zeichen und verarbeitet Informationen
nach logischen Regeln und Schlüssen
deduktiv nennt man das also abgeleitet
Großrechner Schachcomputer z.B auch deep
blue dieses von IBM konstruierte
Schachprogramm der gegen Gary Kasparov
in den 90er Jahren gewonnen hat die
Vorteile sind dass man diese Regeln
eindeutig nachvollziehen kann eindeutig
die Nachteile ist wenig flexibel es
lernt nicht hinzu von sich selbst und es
muss immer wieder von außen neu
gefüttert werden so war das auch damals
bei de blue man musste in den Pausen des
Schachspiels gegen Gary kasperov den
Computer mit neuen Trainingsdaten mit
neuen Daten füttern also ist ziemlich
Star dieses System anders verhält es
sich bei maschinellem lernen oder
neuronalen Netzen das ist das Modell
nicht der symbolverarbeitenden künstlich
Intelligenz das Konnektionismus
neuronale Netze lernen auf Basis von
empirischen Daten gewissermaßen induktiv
also nicht deduktiv sind man kommt auf
die Punkte durch die Durchsicht vieler
Daten leitet die nicht ab die Ergebnisse
sondern abstrahiert Sie Google
spracherkennung ist z Beispiel autonome
Fahrzeuge wobei man hier noch genauer
diskutieren muss wie find die wirklich
autonom sind ein Vorteil ist hier dass
die flexibel sind die lassen sich auf
ganz verschiedene Situationen anwenden
und sie lernen dazu Nachteil die
Ergebnisse sind nur wahrscheinlich und
nicht nachvollziehbar das ist viel zu
komplex was darin vorgeht es ist nicht
mehr logisch deduktiv nach logischen
Gesetzen und Ableitung ich zeige gleich
jetzt wie neuronale Netze funktionieren
also Maschin l lernen es gibt eine
eingabeschicht das ist links da kommt
die Inputs dann gibt's eine verborgene
Schicht die sogenannte Hit layers und
eine
ausgabeschicht also es gibt eine ganz
enge Verknüpfung verschiedener Neuronen
künstliche Neuronen das soll natürlich
unser Gehirn simulieren aber es ist
letztendlich nur eine abstraktions davon
so sieht das aus hier soll jetzt die
dieses Zeichen
dieses geschrift gebildet
schriftgebildet soll erkannt werden das
ist eine zwei und jetzt schaut man wird
das hier durch die verschiedenen
Schichten durchgegeben ganz eng vernetzt
und dann sieht man es wurde richtig
erkannt als sieben bei der z sieht man
es auch es wird hier verarbeitet man
sieht kann gar nicht mehr verstehen was
sie dazwischen stattfindet man sieht nur
die ausgabeschicht also eingabeschicht
und
ausgabeschicht ja bei einigen Sachen
läuft's auch falsch wir können mal
schauen ob das auch richtig erkannt wird
ähm wir haben jetzt hier die 8 und die 2
und die 7 und schauen mal ob die sieben
richtig erkannt wird ja wird richtig
erkannt ne jetzt können wir uns noch ein
weiteres Beispiel anschauen ähm jetzt
haben wir hier wird dieses Zeichen
eingegeben und was wird erkannt es wird
nicht richtig erkannt und wird dann
zurückgegeben das nennt man back
propagation also die Rück Fehler
Rückmeldung das Netz ist sehr dynamisch
mehr möchte ich jetzt auch gar nicht
drauf eingehen das ist jetzt im
Gegensatz zu symbolverarbeitenden KI
maschinelles
Lernen diese künstlichen neuronalen
Netze werden mittlerweile nicht nur in
der Medizin nicht nur in der Ästhetik
nicht nur im der Sprache Kennung
angewendet sonder auch und das ist sehr
problematisch im Krieg in Kontexten des
Militär der militärtechniken und man
sieht jetzt hier die Frage sollten wir
Killerroboter aus den Kriegsszenarien
verbanden sollten wir sie ächten wir
können natürlich auch Mustererkennung in
kriegskontexten einsetzen und dann
wird's schwierig weil dann ist die Frage
wann unterscheidet die KI zwischen
Zivilistinnen oder Kombat Handen das ist
jetzt die Frage kann KI so gut sein
sollten wir KI die Verantwortung
übertragen selbst zwischen Zivilisten
und Kriegsgegnern zu unterscheiden oder
geht das zu weit man kann jetzt zwischen
robotized military Systems
unterscheiden bei denen Menschen immer
in den Scheidungsprozess involviert sind
wenn z.B drohen gesteuert werden es gibt
aber auch noch Lal autonomous weapon
systems sogenannte laws die keine
Menschen mehr in den
Entscheidungsprozess zumindest
unmittelbar durch Steuerung involviert
sind und um diese l dreht sich jetzt die
Debatte ist es inherent also als solches
falsch wenn LS Menschen töten weil sie
dadurch instrumentalisierten zu bloßen
Objekten degradiert werden also macht es
einen Unterschied ob im Krieg Menschen
getötet werden von menschlichen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten oder von
autonomen System macht das ein
Unterschied
ändert sich der moralische Status einer
Handlung wenn Menschen mit
robotized military Systems gesteuerten
System getötet werden oder durch
autonome
Systeme das ist eine Frage eine weitere
Frage betrifft noch die medizinische
Diagnostik man sieht jetzt hier eine
Mitte Mitteilung vom
Universitätsklinikum Heidelberg KI hilft
Therapie Ansprechen von Hirntumoren
besser zu beurteilen es geht also die
mir um die medizinische Diagnostik ein
Urteil soll durch KI gefällt werden
nicht mehr die Ärztin und Ärzte
übernehmen das SN KI H geht das oder
sollte man es immer in Verbund mit
menschlichen Ärzte und Ärzten Fällen
dieses Urteil also die Frage nach
künstlicher Intelligenz in der Medizin
ist eine ganz wichtige Frage
krankheitheiten lassen sich anhand von
bestimmten mustustern erkennen das ist
klar kann künstliche Intelligenz hier
Selbstdiagnosen
stellen kann künstliche Intelligenz nach
diesen diagnos en dann selbst Patienten
behandeln also sollte sie das tun wer
trägt die Verantwortung dafür wenn KI
Behandlungsfehler begeht das sind Fragen
über die man treffen diskutieren kann es
gibt da noch keine abschließende Meinung
dazu und mit zunehmenden technischen
Erfolg werden sich vielleicht auch diese
Diskussion verschieben dass man immer
mehr geneigt sein wird gewisse Aufgaben
zu delegieren die verantwortungsfrage
stellt sich jedch immer noch solange
künstlich Intelligenz nicht wirklich
personale Eigenschaften wie Menschen
aufbeißen kann heutiges Thema jetzt
human enhancement human enhancement
bedeutet die Verbesserung des Menschen
der besseren Verbesserung der
menschlichen Natur hier kann man sich
die Frage stellen in wieefern kann die
Natur des Menschen verbessert werden in
wieefern kann der Mensch durch Technik
verbessert werden das sind
grundsätzliche Fragen und wir sehen
schon hier in diesem Handbuch Technik
Handbuch technikethik wird darauf
ausdrücklich eingegangen die Idee einer
Modifikation körperlicher und geistiger
Leistungsmerkmale des Menschen durch
biotechnische Verfahren ist seit einigen
Jahren Gegenstand einer kontroversen
Debatte hier gibt's schon erste Anfänge
in der ästhetischen Chirurgie also der
Verschönerung des Menschen aber auch
natürlich der
ersatzweisen Korrektur wenn sie
medizinisch angezeigt ist Doping im
Sport
neuroenhancement oder durch
psychopharmakologisches Substanzen also
Leistungssteigerung und so weiter und so
fort also es gibt eigentlich immer schon
die Tendenz den Menschen zu verbessern
nur durch künstliche Intelligenz wird
das Ganze natürlich noch verstärkt hier
stellen sich ganz viele Fragen wie etwa
die moralische Bewertung
dem Respekt vor Autonomie des Prinzip
der Schadensvermeidung
soodass Menschen immer auch aufgeklärt
werden müssen um was sich hierbei
handeln welche Gefahren dabei drohen das
ist die Frage nach der Technik Folgen
Abschätzung es kann nämlich auch
irreversie Eingriffe
geben muss im Sinne der Selbstbestimmung
des Prinzips der Selbstbestimmung das
ist das autonomieprinzip fordern dass
einen möglichen re Recht auf Nutzung von
enhancement Maßnahmen ein Recht auf den
Verzicht entsprechend Eingriffe
korrespondieren muss das heißt man
sollte nicht nur ein Recht darauf haben
dies enhancement Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
oder an sich durchführen zu lassen
sondern auch ein Recht darauf verzichten
zu können das heißt es ist möglich dass
in der Zukunft dieser Druck so groß wird
auf alle Menschen dass man sich
verbessern lassen sollte wenn man das
aber nicht möchte dann sollte man auch
hier das Recht haben darauf zu
verzichten also die Frage nach ob es
eine Pflicht auf
Selbstoptimierung
gibt man befürchtet z.B dass es
gravierende Probleme im Hinblick auf die
persönliche Identität oder
Persönlichkeit von Nutzerin Nutzer gibt
es kann natürlich auch ein sehr
tiefgreifender Eingriff sein der nicht
mehr rückgängig zu machen ist aus einer
anderen Perspektive wurde human
enhancement im Rahmen des
Transhumanismus diskutiert
Transhumanismus bedeutet dass man durch
technische Verbesserung den Menschen
verbessern soll vielleicht sogar eine
Technologie entwickelt die mit dem
Menschen verschmilzt zu einem neuen
besseren Menschen führen das ist ein
ganz wichtiger erfor ein selbst ein
Forscher das Transhumanismus Ray cweil
ein ganz
begnadeter Erfinder der hat z.B
Synthesizer entwickelt aber auch die
Curs reading machine das sebehinderte
Menschen und er vertritt einen
Transhumanismus so sieht das Logo aus
von den transhumanistin und
Transhumanisten es kommt von lateinisch
transjenseits und humanus menschlich das
sollen menschliche Eigenschaften
verbessert werden und der Fortschritt
steht hier im Zentrum also eine ganz
große Fortschrittsgläubigkeit ist damit
verbunden Ray kurswall hat jetzt dieses
Buch geschrieben das singularity is near
when humans transend biology also die
Singularität ist nahe wenn die Menschen
die Biologie überschreiten hier sieht
man ein technifiziertes Gehirn also man
sieht schon maschinelles lehrnen hat
damit was zu tun und ich möchte noch auf
diese Grafik hier eingehen das ist jetzt
ein exponentielles Wachstum was man hier
sieht
dass die technologische Entwicklung
anzeigt man sieht also seit 1900 gibt's
hier ein exponentielles Wachstum was die
menschliche Leistungsfähigkeit anbelangt
und irgendwann im Jahr 2050 sagt jetzt R
KS wird ein Zustand menschlicher
künstlicher Intelligenz erreicht werden
der zu etwas ganz Neuem zu einer
Singularität führt was ist die
Singularität er sagt das wird eine Zeit
sein wo menschliches Leben irreversibel
transformiert wird es ist keine Utopie
keine Dystopie Dystopie heißt eine
Schreckens Zukunftsvision auch keine
Utopie also ein bloßer Wunschzustand s
er sagt es wird Realität sein und
Menschen werden mit der Technik
verschmelzen hier the mer of our
biological thinking and our existence
with our technology es ist also eine
Welt die noch immer menschlich ist aber
die unsere biologischen Wurzeln und auch
schränkungen überschreitet eine dieser
Beschränkung ist z.B unsere
Lebenserwartung die biologisch bedingt
ist wir können natürlich nicht unendlich
lange leben und das ist auch so eine der
Perspektiven des Transhumanismus ja er
bringt hier dann in diesem Buch eine
ganz interessante
Evolutionstheorie der technischen
Entwicklung und die möchte ich mal kurz
vorstellen
m er ist nämlich darin sehr sehr
transzendent transzendent bedeutet sehr
spekulativ so sieht diese
Evolutionstheorie aus wir beginnen mit
der ersten
Evolutionsstufe die haben wir schon
durchlaufen durch Physik und Chemie dann
die DNA dann neuronale Muster und dann
hier die vierte Epoche da sind wir
gerade technologische Epoche Hardware
Computer Technologie entwickelt sich und
hier sieht man hier gibt's ein Übergang
von der biologischen Evolution hin zur
technologischen Evolution und die führt
weiter bis in der Epoche 5 im Jahr 2050
sagte äh Mensch und Technik miteinander
verschmelzen wir brauchen das nicht
weiter diskutieren es geht nur darum
dass zwischen Epoche 3 und 5 eine
Verschmelzung zwischen Mensch und
Technik
stattfinden jetzt kann man darüber
diskutieren inwiefern die Position des
Transhumanismus technikethisch
problematisch ist das werden wir auch
noch tun einer gemeinsam Sitzung jetzt
möchte ich noch zum Schluss einen
Ausblick geben auf die nächste Folge und
nächste Sitzung nämlich wenn es um
antropozen Klimawandel und
technikfolgenabschättzung geht hier
möchte ich auch ein paar Fragen
diskutieren wie ist das Verhältnis
zwischen Mensch und Natur zu bewerten
also soll der Mensch die Natur schützen
hatte eine Verpflichtung die Natur zu
schützen oder kann er auf Kosten der
Natur leben oder sollte er das sogar
hier werden wir einen kleinen Einblick
geben in die Geschichte der
Umweltbewegung Kreta Thunberg neuerdings
wieder aus anderer Perspektive in den
Medien und wir werden vor allem auf den
Begriff des anthropozäns eingehen also
anthropozen ist die menschliche
die Epoche in der der Mensch selbst
Erdgeschichte schreibt weil er so einen
großen Einfluss auf die gesamte Natur
hat hier sieht man ein Cover aus der
Zeitschrift Nature was das sehr gut
zeigt h ist ein menschlicher Körper der
einerseits natürlich ist andererseits
aber auch künstlich ist das wirft
natürlich wieder die Frage nach dem
Transhumanismus auf jetzt bedanke mich
vielmals für die Aufmerksamkeit und man
kann gerne im Anschluss unten im Video
kommentieren